We're not going to 'fix' climate change.
Climate change is a thing that we're
going to be living with now in
perpetual time.
There's not going to be a fix for
sea-level rise, or a fix for droughts, or
anything like that. They're going to be
various adaptations, various ways of
dealing with it, better and worse than
others. But we're not going to fix it.
It's our world now. And this
notion that, you know, the land is here
the sea is there, and we live in this, in
this...because the world that we see is
the world we think is always going to be
there, and has always been there. What
climate change is teaching us is that
the world is in huge flux, and it's
moving around very quickly. And we're
gonna have to live in a rapidly-changing
world. And so how do we think differently
in order to embrace that is, I think, one
of the big questions at the center of
all this.